[Musique]
Véronique prince Michel David Chantal
Hébert bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir On va
commencer ce panel avec cette question
d'un ordre professionnel est-ce que on
devrait comme l'Ontario le fait créé un
ordre professionnel pour les enseignants
pour les enseignants je veux entendre
monsieur Drainville qui dit c'est pas
une bonne idée actuellement là enlevons
ça de la table et monsieur Legault qui a
déjà promis ça je vous fais un extrait
de 2012 c'était dans leur plateforme
électorale je ne l'était plus après le
prêtre honnête faut dire en 2014 mais
quand même c'est dans le programme on
écoute
je trouve pas que c'est une bonne idée
de me lancer dans un processus pour
créer un ordre qui va exercer des
pouvoirs qui existent déjà et par
ailleurs vous savez que cet enjeu-là il
est il ne fait pas consensus chez les
enseignants les enseignants il y en a
qui sont pour il y en a qui sont contre
et donc j'ai pas les moyens présentement
de me lancer dans une dans une dans la
création d'un ordre dans la création
d'un autre professionnel qui va prendre
minimalement 18 mois peut-être deux ans
pourquoi on tient avoir un ordre
professionnel parce que tous les
professionnels que ça soit des
ingénieurs des avocats même des
infirmières des comptables agréés ils
ont tous un ordre professionnel qui
vient s'assurer justement qu'un suivi
qui soit fait de la formation continue
de la mise à jour donc des connaissances
des professionnels
Véronique prince donc c'était jadis
aujourd'hui on le sous-texte un peu du
ministre corrigez-moi si je me trouve
c'est un peu dire il y a assez de faire
au feu avec les syndicats on veut de la
souplesse ici et là on va pas en plus
rajouter cette question d'un ordre
professionnel Véronique c'est ça moi ce
que je retiens c'est la dernière phrase
de Samuel et 13 quand il dit j'ai pas
les moyens de me lancer dans un
processus qui fait pas consensus puis
qui pourrait me prendre deux ans parce
qu'en fait c'est ça la réalité de
Bernard Rainville c'est qu'en ce moment
il doit éteindre des feux puis il y a
probablement une question qui est encore
plus fondamentale que se demander est-ce
qu'on a besoin d'un ordre ou non la
question plus fondamentale c'est
qu'est-ce qui est à la base de ça en
fait c'est quoi le problème pourquoi on
a des enseignants qui sont about souffle
en ce moment à ce que c'est un problème
encore une fois de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre d'ampleur de la tâche je compte
sur le travail est-ce que trouver dans
les classes trop d'élèves problématiques
il y a toutes sortes de questions en ce
moment qui sont à se poser et Bernard
Rainville son argument c'est dire on
créer en fait on a pas créé parce que ça
existait déjà mais il faisait pas grand
chose vous allez me dire mais le
protecteur de l'élève c'est pouvoir ont
été renforcés et c'est pouvoir renforcer
là on va en voir la preuve à la
prochaine rentrée scolaire alors lui
c'est comme si vous êtes donné dans la
chance au coureur avant de me réclamer
un autre professionnel
[Musique]
une bonne idée ou mauvais moment c'est
une mauvaise idée en politique et je
pense que Monsieur drinville sur le fond
ce serait plutôt en faveur comme
Monsieur le Gaulle l'était et comme les
libéraux de Jean Charrel étaient en 2004
je pense pierre-y qui était ministre de
l'éducation à l'époque avait promis un
avant projet de loi là-dessus et comme
ceux qui l'ont qui l'ont suivi il y a
abandonné l'idée devant la mobilisation
écoutez il y avait des sondages je pense
c'était 98 % des enseignants qui est à
compte alors ça part mal de négociation
alors d'une part c'est vrai actuellement
on est en train de négocier mais aussi
on est en pénurie et
lors d'un mauvaise presse auprès des
enseignants est présumément auprès des
des apprentis enseignants si je peux
dire des étudiants alors c'est déjà
difficile d'en attirer si en plus on
ajoute ce qui est perçu comme un chiffon
rouge par les enseignants bah ça va être
encore plus difficile alors l'idée sur
le fond moi je pense que ça allait
excellente mais actuellement c'est c'est
pas là Chantal
deux choses d'abord oui c'est vrai il y
a des situations de stress dans les
écoles qui sont réelles mais il faudrait
pas que ça devienne cet épisode et ceux
qu'on voit cette semaine une espèce
d'excuse pour dire c'est parce que
l'emploi est trop stressant et donc il
faut se pencher sur des conditions de
travail c'est intéressant mais il y a un
autre angle et la question se relie à
votre ordre professionnelle c'est à dire
même s'il y avait eu un ordre
professionnel en place comme en Ontario
est-ce que ça aurait réglé le problème
de l'omerta pas celle des enfants mais
l'omerta qui assainies dans cette école
là où on devait avoir entendu ces ce qui
se passait et où néanmoins il y a pas
d'adultes qui sont portés à la défense
des enfants
et d'ailleurs en deux ça c'est encore
plus avant mais je vous la ferai pas
entendre en 2011 monsieur Legault avant
de créer le parti avait dit il faut
redonner du pouvoir aux écoles aux
établissements qui a un vrai patron
derrière ça rappelle un peu le discours
sur le siège SLD
que les directrices d'écoles directeur
d'école elle et coût des franges pour
régler pour éviter ce genre de mère là
très bien
mais ça se fera pas de toute façon je
reviens sur le troisième lien le
monsieur Legault ce matin vous allez
l'entendre vous fait entendre d'abord
hier faut reculer ailleurs pour bien
comprendre à l'étude des crédits
monsieur Legault se fait talonner à
donnez-nous les chiffres c'est caviaret
de votre nouveau projet le troisième
lien mais avec transport en commun
uniquement donnez-nous les chiffres
pourquoi pas on écoute ça et la
re-réponse de Monsieur Lebeau ce matin
dans la version longue il y a une
estimation des coûts de chaque scénario
mais les coûts sont caviés dans la
version courte que le premier ministre a
consulté est-ce que les coûts étaient
caviés non non donc le premier ministre
connaît contrairement à moi les chiffres
qui sont censés être ici non ils
viennent me dire des chiffres Premier
ministre
dans la version longue que je n'ai pas
vu dans la version courte il y avait pas
d'estimation
probablement qu'on parle d'un tunnel
avec des autobus comme je vous ai dit
nous actuellement on exclut pas que ça
soit un métro que ça soit un tramway que
ça soit un REM comme à Montréal donc
faut évidemment regarder quelle sorte de
transport collectif il y aura dans le
tunnel avant d'être capable de vous
donner une estimée vous avez pas demandé
nos chiffres qui est inscrits c'est un
estimé qui est sommaire et ce que je
veux c'est de voir quelle forme va
prendre le
transport collectif puisqu'elle va être
le tracé
à la question là pour bien comprendre le
journal donc vous-même vous dites vous
les savez pas vous-même il dit non non
moi je veux je pars rendu là Chantal
bon alors ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'on
a pas modifié le projet de troisième
lien la semaine dernière puis on y
retournait à la case départ et la case
départ de Beaba
je ne sais pas dit le Premier ministre
peut-être qu'il voulait pas le savoir
parce que c'était pas important parce
que franchement on cherchait une
position de repli mais on en a rien à
dire parce que elle est pour l'instant
tiens ça une feuille de papier ou une
serviette de table une table où on
aurait élaboré une stratégie de recul
sur le troisième lien automobile Michel
David et il n'a pas fini de se faire
poser des questions sur ça avant de le
promettre avez-vous des chiffres oui
mais c'est pas de chiffres comment
pouvez-vous le promettre etc exactement
on peut pas dire que monsieur Legault
apprend pas de ses erreurs il les répète
à la perfection et c'est exactement ce
qui est arrivé la première fois il s'est
lancé dans un projet le premier je sais
pas combien de fois sans avoir la
moindre idée du coût de l'ensemble des
implications et il nous refait le même
coup je trouve ça assez hallucinant et
connaissant monsieur Legault là c'est un
comptable c'est un fruit de chiffre
presque autant que Christian Dubé je
peux pas imaginer qui commence à évoquer
des hypothèses comme celle-là sans même
peut-être pas parler mais même pas les
avoir vu lui-même demandé aller voir sa
nettement j'avale pas ça Véronique
pourquoi au gouvernement ne dit pas on
aimerait que le troisième lien soit
éventuellement un lien de transport
quand même mais on va faire nos devoirs
on vous reviendra avec une proposition
ou pas c'est comme dit Michel c'est
comme si on apprenait pas ce qu'on
prenait avant d'avoir des détails
c'est dur à croire parce que le cabinet
du premier ministre est généralement
tellement impliqué dans les gros projets
qui lui tiennent à cœur c'est difficile
de s'imaginer qu'il y a pas au moins un
ordre de grandeur qui peut nous donner
d'autant plus que le coût justement
quand Michel dit il doit apprendre de
ses erreurs
dans le projet autoroutier ce qu'il le
fait la mandoline c'est pas juste le
problème d'achat Landa sur les ponts qui
a diminué c'est aussi le coût qui était
trop élevé alors il s'était engagé une
première fois avec un coup trop élevé et
là du reculer en grande partie pour la
raison du coup alors là il s'engage de
nouveau dans un autre projet sans avoir
les coûts alors ça sème le doute sur la
fermeté de cet engage là c'est pour ça
je vais dire comme mes collègues on a
une impression de déjà-vu là est-ce que
c'est une façon de se rabattre de dire
mais je donne pas la portion autoritaire
mais je ne brise pas la promesse je
n'abandonne pas le projet de troisième
lien il y en a quand même un qui est un
tunnel de transport collectif alors
pourquoi pas racheter du blaster
complètement à ce moment-là ce qu'on se
demande
juste dans la phrase les gros projets
qui lui tiennent à coeur ici on est
devant un gros projet qui peut être ne
lui tient pas à coeur et rajoutons à ça
l'incertitude le 40% garanti par le
fédéral ouais
mais pas sur pied à poiler mais on est
un peu dans l'improvisation oui parce
que Pierre pollièvre rappelons-le a dit
moi je donnerai pas un sou si je deviens
Premier ministre pour un tunnel où il y
aurait pas d'auto
réaliste Michel j'avais écrit une
chronique ce matin
en parlant de moutons en parlant du
caucus qu'elle est revenu
qu'elle est revenue à de meilleurs
sentiments parce qu'ils ont ils ont des
jobs ou des ministres etc
n'empêche est-ce que ça ne laisse pas
croyez-vous pour un bon bout de temps
une crise en tout cas un nouveau sujet à
gérer pour le bureau du premier ministre
oui pendant un bout de temps mais je
pense que ça va rentrer dans l'ordre au
sein du caucus les gens de surtout de la
réussite de Québec vont mettre du temps
à digérer mais vous savez la politique
une mauvaise nouvelle chasse l'autre
alors il va y avoir dans un avenir
proche je sais pas ce que ça va être ça
peut être une crise en santé ça peut
être il va y avoir d'autres sujets de
préoccupation qui sur lesquelles les
députés vont être appelés à se
concentrer alors si ceux qui avaient à
partir ne sont pas partis ils partiront
pas alors dans mon esprit moi sur le
plan de l'autorité de monsieur Legault
sur son focus la question est réglée
trace moi je pense quand même que ça va
laisser une trace parce que les c'est la
première crise interne que François
Legault a à gérer depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir c'est la première fois que il y
a des députés qui ont été blessés là qui
ont été blessés par ce que il y a pas il
a manqué de communication avec eux en
même temps ça lance un message aux
autres députés des autres régions pour
d'autres dossiers qui les concernent
davantage que ça se peut que ça leur
arrive éventuellement qu'elle va qu'une
décision soit prise sans qu'il soit
consultée Véronique a raison mais je
pense qu'il y en a peut-être qui vont
décider de ne pas se représenter mais de
là à partir en cours de mandat d'autant
plus que maintenant quand on part avant
la fin du mandat on n'a pas droit à une
indemnité de départ c'est c'est assez
disons de dissuada
je pense pas qu'on va avoir et pour
partir en voyage ou en politique il faut
encore avoir un ailleurs
et dans ce cas-ci on n'a pas d'ailleurs
de l'autre côté de l'Assemblée nationale
et pas tout le monde a un grand tailleur
à l'extérieur de l'Assemblée nationale
donc très bien nos valeurs et on va
parler du frère de Monsieur Trudeau
Alexandre Trudeau qui s'occupe de la
Fondation lui s'en occupe activement
je vous je vous donne deux citations
rapidement dans une entrevue au Devoir
la Fondation dit-il n'a rien fait de mal
il n'y a aucune tentative encore moins
d'ingérence étrangère les donateurs
n'avaient pas de mauvaises intentions
ils parlent des de cette entreprise
chinoise je veux témoigner ajouter
devant le comité qui s'en occupe je suis
prêt à dire tout ce que je sais sur la
fondation et ça presse a jeter ça tombe
bien c'est le conservateur veulent
l'entendre Chantal Hébert est-ce que
Alexandre tu te trouves va venir sauver
la Fondation Trudeau
oh ça va prendre plus que ça pour sauver
la Fondation twidow la vraie question
c'est est-ce que
Alexandre Trudeau va venir sauver son
frère et je pense que c'est plutôt le
contraire c'est comme l'impression moi
qu'au bureau du Premier ministre en
voyant tout ça on s'est dit oh non
écoutez les libéraux venaient de
convenir avec les néo démocrate
entre autres au comité qu'on allait
faire venir des témoins mais qu'on
excluait les membres de la famille
Trudeau ou des élus et puis là tout à
coup de nulle part le frère du Premier
ministre pour ramener tout ça dans le
giron familial donc au niveau politique
dit oh non non moi j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire
je suis convaincu que Monsieur Trudeau
s'il veut se faire entendre va se faire
entendre on peut pas refuser selon moi
au comité mais d'autre part que ce sera
pour le gouvernement la dernière chose
qu'on souhaitait Michel oui très
certainement je sais pas quelle question
on va poser à Monsieur à Monsieur
Trudeau frères il va certainement dire
bon non mon frère on se parle pas de ça
puis il était pas au courant mais on va
lui dire écoutez le monsieur monsieur
zangle c'est ma mémoire est bonne le
milliardaire étiez vous au courant que
ce gars était ni plus ni moins qu'un
adjoint du régime communiste non ah bon
ben vous êtes pas curieux d'une manière
ou d'une autre il va s'enférer je vois
pas comment il peut sortir quelque chose
de positif pour l'image de la fondation
et de Monsieur Trudeau les deux des deux
Trudeau
ici on veut poursuivre sur d'autres
sujets d'administration je voyais
aujourd'hui une chronique dans la presse
qui nous apprenait que au plan de la
gestion c'est c'est pas hebdomadaire
écoutez il y a plus de 40% je pense des
revenus qui sont qui sont affectés à la
rémunération des dirigeants là c'est à
peu près
il y a pas d'équivalence dans les
fondations du même du même niveau alors
français dans la presse voilà exactement
il y a rien de bon qui peut sortir je
pense pour le gouvernement de cette
histoire là Véronique je me demande
aussi qu'est-ce que le témoignage peut
apporter dans la réalité parce que
l'image est déjà entachée la Fondation
peu importe ce qui va dire est-ce que ça
va renverser la mauvaise presse il part
avec un déficit de crédibilité à cause
de ça alors même si son témoignage est
excellent qui fait plein de révélations
est-ce que ça va suffire à renverser
l'image qui s'est créée autour de cette
fondation là à cause de son nom et à
cause de tout ça donc j'ai des doutes je
me demande ce que ça peut apporter
mais en fait ça va confirmer
l'impression que c'est une fille du scie
familiale qui est l'impression que les
conservateurs veulent donner c'est
peut-être pas ça mais ça va exactement
dans le sens du message des
conservateurs
encore moins d'ingérence étrangère
autant les services canadiens peuvent
pas être sûr de ça on l'a déjà établi
autant lui peut pas être comme un peu
savoir ça c'est le président chil lui a
pas dit non non t'inquiète pas enfin
bref comme il nous reste de temps
c'est terminé Véronique Michel Chantal
bonne soirée on se reparle de tout ça et
de d'autres sujets plus tard merci au
revoir